apparently if you type in the jungle
book and the jungle book it's the same
exact movie huh hey my name is Greg this
is John we're gonna talk about the
jungle book 2016 brought to you by Jon
Favreau yeah Jon Favreau's the jungle
book
buddy it is one of the best live
adaptations of these Disney movies or
whatever they've done it's probably the
best one in my opinion I I think I think
it's fantastic and I feel like this is
finally kind of nailing that thing we've
been trying to do forever with like
let's take a beloved Disney movie and
make it real life but also gritty can't
feel like this movie has struck the
translation the best way because it is
like real I guess a little more perilous
because it's live-action it's a real kid
but like it still has tons and tons of
spirit yeah and that's what a lot of the
other ones lack for me is is you know
soul no this movie has this look that's
the perfect word for it there's a spirit
to it there's a personality the scope of
it is totally spectacular to look at
yeah visual effects are amazing like
you're gonna touch on the visual effects
I gotta say the animals the way they're
done oh they move like real animals
even the background every little tidbit
to them every movement the way they
climb and everything
it's like watching real animals that
yeah they've come a long way with that
tech like like really being able to
animate all the face muscles and all the
movement like hair has gotten so much
better than hairs has ever been I'm
looking at this movie and I'm like dang
this is a movie with one human a great a
great kid the kid with the plane mobley
wasn't a Neal Smith or something I don't
sure if it's Neel Sethi or Neel Sethi
but ya know he was he was great he was
yeah he was sincere he was genuine he
was very animated he was a real kid they
got you felt like a real kid he had this
like there were times when even like
he'd be a little green and that almost
made it better for me like it almost
made it feel more alive the end of the
day like it he's really great because
he's super genuinely Nita they needed a
kid who could work off his imagination
because this is a green screen he's
dealing with the entire time but his
back and forth that he has with the
animals and the different dynamics with
them it doesn't sound like he's ever
just reading from a script you could
tell his like
his dialogue sometimes forms based off
the way this actor said it to him and
stuff like he's a he's a kid who's
actually listening and responding and I
think he doesn't I think that's great
job and he he is the only human
character that we follow in this movie I
was on board for the whole adventure I
was rooting for him the whole time I
really cared about him and I gotta say
too in terms of visuals whenever like
Mowgli was doing something that was you
know a little out of the ordinary of
what humans do didn't look I see Chiaki
it looks like a real kid they do a good
job like of kind of bridging the gap
between the cartoon of the movie because
they do borrow some design things from
that they do use some of those visual
motifs but in more realistic ways like
in the COS scene like when she's coming
towards him I swear
I don't remember really great because
I've seen the jungle book and I made a
movie in a while but I feel like the
snake's eye is like bug out in that kind
of blue yellow blue yellow away and they
even worked that into a movie in a way
that was so subtle I can catch it for a
couple of seconds yeah you know they
allowed those scenes to be really
natural cuz like the costume is like
creepy and like creepy and it's cool
that they allow the movie to just be the
situation's just be what they are
yes that's what makes Shere Khan so
scary is like Shere Khan is allowed to
be you know he's he has a point but he's
also scary about it and you get why he's
dubbed doing what he's doing but he's
also kind of bad guy Idris Elba does a
great job on voicing him yeah like Idris
Elba's voice for that character was he
made that character was scary it was a
scary [ __ ] tiger man eat yourself but
also everybody because like this movie
has a lot of people on the voice cast
who we liked enough or who are good
enough right now to just kind of be
themselves a lot they didn't do that cuz
like II drew salba couldn't just be a
Giselle but I thought he brought nuanced
yeah and Ben Kingsley did the same thing
as Bagheera granted he's Ben Kingsley
he's stately enough but I feel like the
nuances were on it and Bill Murray like
maybe the biggest surprises to me I like
how well I thought he worked in the film
he plays it like a bear it's not just
like oh yeah the voice and it's fun and
you know it's animated it's like he
really plays the performance and walk
into like you know I gotta say this is
our like third time shooting this and he
just like to
other things I'm sorry I think you're
gonna jump there's things that I had
said and I was like wait and I was just
saying things that I actually said at
some points and now it's like well done
on that point we don't have points
anymore
I'm out of points take life no we're out
doing in there tape we're gonna do this
one guys that's like you just keep
rambling yeah yeah I'm gonna cover Bill
Murray Ben Kingsley and I'm gonna cover
some people give him up you jump it like
I'm used to you know beginning let me
interrupt when people talk alright that
maybe you like two in a row I'm gonna
run this is raw footage okay one thing I
really appreciate about this film was
that they're not just you know celebrity
voices these are people who were like
specifically cast for each one you know
Scarlett Johansson I felt was
specifically cast for that which is one
scene and she does a great job in
resemble of course and there was some of
Bill Murray's best work he's done in a
very long time and it was somewhat
Christopher Walken's best where he's
done in a very long time all these
characters they're specific they're
really defined and they're really
brought to life in this movie yeah now
you go okay I just like to give props to
the screenwriter because he wrote Street
Fighter The Legend of chun-li before
this nice and I think that's that's
about it other than some shorts and
stuff so major improvement
I don't think Ben Kingsley was just
being Ben Kingsley like the way you were
kind of putting and I felt like you were
kind of me not putting him down his
performance a little bit as if it wasn't
that it all has great me you know Ben
Kingsley can be an [ __ ] a lot of the
time you keep thanked easily is usually
a more complex dude like this was a guy
who was like kind of the Buddha of the
story but it's it's what you said before
there's a level of commitment to all
these characters that especially for the
actors who don't have to who are good
enough that they don't have to commit
super hard like I felt like they still
did and I could tell Ben Kingsley you
might go in and go what's not super
different from Ben Kingsley but like the
fine points you know the little nuances
are really on point and no strangers out
with the same goes for walk in and the
same goes for Bill Murray who
what's-her-name Lupita Nyong'o
yeah she she plays the wolf who takes
care of
the mother wolf of Mowgli and I really
like that relationship I really cared
about their dynamics you could tell that
there was a real mother-son touch to
their relationship and I got I don't
know I mean we really love her any other
little Cubs that they had it works that
much better because like they establish
they do address in small ways the
weirdness of what Mowgli is and having
him around and they build that into
their relationship it's not just you're
a wolf it's like you're a member of our
family you're a bit different so you got
to do some different stuff but like we
love you and you get the friction and
you get you know it's it's just like
little touches like that
wait there's great themes of like
segregation and equality that are being
at play here in this movie and I really
like it I like it's a great family movie
because it's a film that is a real film
for all ages it's not like this is good
for kids and parents can endure it it's
like no I think their parents we might
like it more than some of the kids movie
the stuff that that it brings up is
stuff for everybody it's appropriately
genuine you know like there are times
when it is scarier or or kind of creepy
and it's not too much nothing is ever
too much and nothing's ever too flashy
for me I would totally recommend
watching this on IMAX because the day
the 3ds not bad like it was definitely
cool to see it big and the only thing is
like I I wish on IMAX it could have been
all IMAX just because that would have
been so it was I still thought it was
very immersive oh that's not I felt like
I was like really a part of this world
like it was a very defined jungle we
were exploring very defined without ever
like stopping to go these are the rules
yeah exactly like I felt like Jon
Favreau really loves this story he just
wanted to bring it to life and a very
genuine we could feel the heart and the
love of the Jungle Book
when you're watching it it is a
fantastic movie it has a very sort of
native tribal quality you know like a
lot of people have been comparing this
movie to Avatar you know like and yeah
there are similar themes like tribal
wise and and then I think about you know
how most of avatars you know what CGI
and CGI characters and like this movie
has one here
pretty much and a whole bunch of CGI yet
I thought this movie was way more
immersive
I actually really believed it and I like
being in this world you know well
because I think the thing that avatar
lacks is like this stuff I walked away
from that movie with was like it is
beautiful in a tribal kind of way and in
a nature a very earthy way and they [ __ ]
about the story at the end of it but but
that's the that's the thing is that what
what I feel like jungle book has that
avatar doesn't is like avatar has such a
standard like such a well-worn story the
bad guy is like an angry army dude in a
mech suit like it's like you know it's
it's black and white and the good guys
and the bad guys and then one dude
learns and turns it on like this is a
little more like you get the sense for
community and you get why Mowgli has to
do certain things alone it feels less
plot even avatar does like avatar still
wants to be a big action movie - and I
don't feel like this wants to do that
dude this movie does you know like I
know they got a jungle book - green that
already and I'm sure it's because of how
well it's performed and everything but
the way they grow Mowgli in this story
and they're like the arc he goes through
this symbol he becomes of the jungle I
could totally feel I'm totally on board
yeah I could see this like story keep
going you know like because I'm invested
in Mowgli like the commercials and
trailers make you go I want to check out
the CGI and the animals and the voice
actors but this story makes me invested
enough in Mowgli that I would love to
see the Mowgli story continue I love to
see the Mowgli story continue as long as
there are more animals
I mean Oh totally yeah I mean like the I
want a one-man-show Mowgli just mine
upon tree those movies were like
nothing's too flashing the part where
like everybody feels like they're on the
same level in the same movie and like
yeah that's real nice it's like
everything is necessary and and in
quality I know there's a second Jungle
Book book I don't know I I don't want
them to just franchise the [ __ ] out of
this because like I think they could I
think like this one's kind of I want
that this one could be kind of special
and like you know but I'm confident that
team will do a good job it kind of makes
me a little sick to be like ah it's not
even out you and we already have a part
too
jungle boat to water animals Mowgli goes
to the ocean the ocean book right -
Mowgli takes on insects he shrinks down
a part of three Mowgli gets a dog I wish
I was Mowgli it sounds like it like
nothing hurts his feet just walks around
the jungle all is too good I was like I
was thinking I know Mowgli's used to
this I wonder how yeah I've been super
comfortable I'm like oh God not wearing
shoes in that jungle song that's gonna
hurt you yeah they brought the songs in
the movie which I was that was another
one of those things going in I was like
are they going to and how is it gonna
work and for the most part I thought
that'd work cuz they be them kind of
have specially the way they went and
they made bare necessities work I
thought that was great
cuz that one almost kind of comes out is
just like a ditty he's singing it it
becomes a musical number but it doesn't
start as one so just feel like it's a
it's a great scene yeah it is like like
it's a great bonding moment with Mowgli
and Bill Murray Baloo cuz yeah cuz they
are just kind of floating down the
stream and just like enjoying a nice day
just just enjoying watching them have a
good time together
and it's kind of refreshing to see such
joy Montano the songs start in an
understated way yeah and then and then I
want to be like you with King Louie is a
similar kind of understanding and I know
some people really prefer you know the
version from the animated movie but I
thought Chris Walken did a great like
well yeah it's got that you know like
real jazz and and this one is a little
more sinister yeah yeah so out of place
to his character well yeah I appreciated
that they took the songs they still did
them but they they fit them to the movie
yeah in a different way I thought cause
song was great Jack Black is the Panda
that was great cross
DreamWorks and Disney should work
together to get become food panic
characters Mobley goes to China
oh it would be different but it wouldn't
be well it would be very telling you man
they could franchise itself this is the
second earnings for the rest of his life
keeps growing watch this guy change into
old Mowgli and you're like Dean this guy
still doesn't hang out humans he's just
he's just only he doesn't even know what
sexes some like [ __ ] like what
well no go for it comes along and is
like oh man I've never had sex with a
human
no I feel like Mowgli would inevitably
learn because animals don't be [ __ ]
at some point so like he's gonna be like
what the hell are you doing yeah he's
maybe that's a sequel right there we
gotta find Mowgli a human girl doesn't
match that creepy move you had yeah no
and then he has to raise this baby in
the jungle and Izzy's an emotionally
abusive husband is like why just like I
want to go back to Len and see my family
and like this is your new family well
guys I give this movie's awesome tacular
five out of five snows a plus John
really likes it too yeah I liked it a
lot yeah there's our summary if you're
new to the channel subscribe today
become a rejects John has playlists on
this channel check them out follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and if you
have my cell phone number give me a call
sometime take care now bye bye thank you
to tell me for doing the camera